the 24 inch m1 imac has been one of the
most controversial product launches in
years
for two reasons but neither of them
really make or break your purchasing
decision like the little secret the
apple conveniently didn't mention at
their launch event
which can make a world of a difference
in your day-to-day use
in this detailed review i will cover
both of those things along with our new
findings based on real world experience
after two weeks of using this machine
in a wide variety of tasks from simple
use all the way up to replacing a more
powerful and more expensive 27-inch imac
for professional use and i'll finish off
this video with a key software fix
and some clear recommendations on which
models and which upgrades you should buy
based on your use case which will either
save you money
or headaches since we actually purchased
two imacs
a base model and a high end with twice
the ram
and found significant differences
depending on what you'll use it for
now let me warn you up front i am a huge
fan of this imac
so a lot of this will be very positive
but trust me
i will call apple out on the few things
that are actually wrong
with this machine the 24 inch imac is
the new standard desktop mac that
replaces the long outdated 21.5 inch
imac
and if you're wanting to upgrade from
one of those this new mac will be a huge
improvement in
every way but one now the first thing
you'll notice is the new striking or
shocking design
now i want to spend a little bit more
time on this than usual because there's
a lot of confusion and controversy on
this
which i was also a part of until we
actually spent more time
with this machine this is the first time
apple has made such a drastic
design change since 2007 where they went
from a plastic
white bezel 20 inch imac to the 24 inch
aluminum design that had been slowly and
slightly modified since then
this new imac combines both of those
machines along with colors that we
haven't seen
since the now vintage g3 imax from 1998
that i used to use at school as a kid
this new 2021 imac
is a great nod to apple's heritage all
the way back to the original imac hello
but it is more premium looking and
feeling than before because it's made of
all
aluminum with a full sheet of laminated
glass on the front
the white bezel and color options give
this machine a very consumer friendly
look
but trust me on the inside apple's m1
chip makes this imac pack
way more of a punch than previous imax
did for their price
so much so that it beats out my 15 000
imac pro
in some professional tasks which never
happened with previous entry-level imacs
but more on performance in just a bit
also if you're like most people who
enjoy our videos but haven't hit that
subscribe button
now is a perfect time since you guys can
help us reach our goal
of 1 million subscribers before the end
of the year we would greatly appreciate
it
a ton of people complained about apple's
decision to use white bezels
so much so that third party companies
started making stickers
to change them back to black mostly
because black helps you focus on the
content of the display
or at least that's what people say but
after using it i have to say that i am
loving the white bezels at least when
using it in a normally lit room
and against a white wall that most homes
have
after the first day your eyes get used
to it and the bezels blend into the
background and it's almost like your
content
is floating there in mid-air and in dark
rooms it's not as distracting as i
expected
because the bezel isn't actually white
but it is great
what was even more of a controversy was
the big chin the apple left on the imac
what's inside of there is very
impressive at least on the higher end
model
but it is the look that people are
hating on apple could have easily gotten
rid of it and had a nice slim bezel all
around
just like the pro display xdr but they
didn't and there's a good reason for it
that i now
agree with no it's not because they want
this machine to be as
thin as possible which it is so thin
that they had to put the headphone jack
on the side
but it is because the chin is imac's
standout design feature
that is now so iconic that even windows
pc companies have started to make their
all-in-one
chins larger all while slimming down
their bezels
ultralinks pointed out best on twitter a
chin makes the imac
instantly recognizable just like the
notch on the iphone makes it stand out
instead of looking like every other
smartphone finishing off the design
the imac is modern friendly and it
definitely looks brand new
all while being recognizable even
without the apple logo
that i do wish they kept and no you
can't just use the sticker that is
included
because it is too big they made sure
that you wouldn't be able to just put it
there
the colors are subtle on the front and
striking on the back
and they're a little bit more bold in
person than on apple's website
personally i prefer the classic silver
but overall the design gets a big thumbs
up for me
and it will stay looking new for a long
time getting into hardware
this is where things start turning for
the worst and i have two main complaints
and two minor ones the first one is the
ports
on the base model we are losing four usb
type a ports an sd
card reader and an ethernet jack now yes
those new thunderbolt ports are powerful
and they can be greatly expanded
like we showed off in our owc hub video
which you can watch after this one but
that's just one more thing to buy and
have to plug into the imac
and into wall power the high end gives
you ethernet in the power adapter which
is extremely clever
and two more usb type-c ports that don't
support thunderbolt
in real-world use this has been a pain
coming from
an older mac and we've already been
having to plug in and unplug things
to make it work now i know that usb
type-c is the future and this isn't a
pro machine but apple is rumored to be
adding back ports and an sd card reader
into the upcoming macbook
so why not just include that sd card
reader here on the side
by the headphone jack the next one is
the ethernet jack that is limited to the
much older and slower
one gigabit ethernet apple has been
offering 10 gigabit ethernet for a few
years now
and they just added it as an option to
the m1 mac mini
so if someone is going to use ethernet
why not give us the full speed one
on that note i have to point out how
impressive apple's new accessories are
the tension to detail and everything all
the way up to the thick cloth handle on
the box is shockingly good
for a 1299 base level device
the wires on the charging cable are
color matched and braided as is the
cable leading up to the imac
itself which ends in a new round max 8
connector
that is also color matched and anodized
even though max safe isn't a necessity
for a desktop it's been a joy to use
as it connects almost magically lining
up and snapping into place and looking
super clean and premium this would have
been the perfect time to finally move
the charge port from the bottom
where your mouse can't be used while
charging but at least the mouse charges
fast and lasts a long time
onto the keyboard i absolutely love it
and i think it's definitely worth
spending the extra fifty dollars
to upgrade to the touch id version from
the base imax keyboard
not only can you speed up logging in and
make it much more secure
it's also useful for apple pay passwords
and more in macos
what's even cooler is if you have
multiple people sharing an imac
you can quickly go to your profile using
touch id the updated keyboard also feels
slightly better and quieter than my new
mac pro's keyboard when typing
and my only complaint on the keyboard is
that the launchpad shortcut is now gone
so i can't quickly open up the app
launcher to fix this you can remap a
shortcut like the command
and spacebar button together or use the
new spotlight shortcut and just search
for the app that you need
the next minor disappointment are the
speakers and not because they are bad
they are actually quite good for such a
thin machine but because apple hyped
them up
so much by saying they are the best in
any imac
which i don't agree with apple spent a
considerable amount of time designing
these with six total speakers and
vibration cancelling woofers
that are connected to a very large but
super thin enclosure
that spans most of the imac sandwich
between the display
and the aluminum chassis this increases
the sound quality and bass response of
the speakers but it's still not enough
to make them the best
go ahead and listen for yourself how
they compare to the 27-inch imac
[Music]
[Laughter]
so
now sure it might be better than the
imac that it directly replaces
but they still lack bass compared to the
larger imax which makes a big difference
for music
movies and games they also don't get
super loud
for most people they will do a decent
job and you won't need to get dedicated
speakers but i would definitely prefer
apple's previous ones as far as the
display it is fantastic
we've already talked about the bezels
but the screen is just as color accurate
and sharp as apple's 5k or 6a displays
since they've upped the resolution from
4k on the older 21.5 inch
to 4.5 k to keep that perfect 218 pixels
per inch for apple's retina rating
24 inches or 23.5 to be exact is a great
size for a consumer related computer
it is big enough to do everything from
web browsing to photo and video editing
and it won't look huge in people's homes
now if you're coming from a 27-inch you
will definitely notice the size
difference
especially for pro work where you need
to multitask but if you're wanting a
downsize
you do get used to the smaller display
after a day or two
and if you're coming from a windows pc
or much older imax
it will blow you away with great detail
colors
and 500 nits of brightness and great
coatings that fight reflections in
bright rooms
the display alone is worth at least
seven hundred dollars
like lg's ultra fine 24 inch display
which has the same brightness and color
accuracy but has a lower 4k resolution
above the display is the first 1080p
webcam and any mac
under 5 000. check out the webcam and my
quality improvements
this is the webcam and microphone
quality on the 2020
27 imac with the 720p facetime camera
and this is the webcam and microphone
quality on the 2021
24-inch imac with the 1080p facetime
camera
and the m1 isp the image is both
brighter and sharper and the microphones
are more clear as well
now i do think that both are a little
bit too flat compared to the older macs
but on the plus side it makes web
conferencing much more clear which is a
good thing
and apple could still tweak this down
the line with software
and now for the biggest disappointment
with the new 24 inch m1 imac
something that can either make or break
your experience and even longevity of
this machine
and something that apple could have
easily fixed for just a few dollars per
machine
but instead they didn't even mention it
to us
and that is the fact that the base model
is purposefully
gimped which makes a huge difference in
real world usage
when apple announced this imac they
showed off how almost all of the
components are stuffed inside of the
chin
and the super efficient m1 chip is
cooled with only two fans
and they even went as far as saying that
under most workloads
it runs at 10 decibels which is quieter
than most
background noise now all of this is true
but only if you buy the 1500
model it is pretty much silent even when
doing video or photo editing
and even gaming all while the computer
stays cool as well
even though the high-end model has more
powerful graphics
for the entry level model though apple
got rid of one of the fans
and it's the one that had a heat pipe
connected to it
leaving the left side fan which just
blows cool air inside of the system
and doesn't have a heat sink leaving the
m1 chip
just sitting there heating up like in
the fanless macbook air
the performance is 10 to 15 percent
worse depending on what you're doing
and up to 25 percent worse if you're
pushing both the cpu and the graphics at
the same time
now it's 10 more performance on an
already fast ship
worth an extra 200 if you don't need the
other improvements
maybe maybe not but 25
definitely is worth spending more for so
maybe that's why apple decided to leave
out
the main cooling component that cost
them just a few dollars to include
because of that when pushing the machine
the base model cpu runs
at extremely hot 95 degrees celsius
and when gaming the graphics core also
runs at 95 degrees celsius
and the only reason they don't get
hotter is that the m1 chip is slowed
down
from the full 3.2 gigahertz performance
down to 2.5
now the same thing does happen to the m1
macbook air but the difference is
that machine is designed to be mobile
where this is a desktop that doesn't
rely on battery power
and the air is fanless so it is totally
silent while this still has
a single but barely effective fan that
spins up often and under heavier
productive loads
it runs at full blast while its m1 chip
is running
slower and super hot during most of
these tasks the more expensive imax fans
are running at their slowest possible
speeds
while running cool and completely silent
and
under extreme loads the fans barely spin
up from idle
for example in our red export test the
m1 was at 71 degrees celsius and barely
audible
compared to the single fan imac at 95
degrees celsius
and the fan at 7 000 rpm why do you have
to do this to us apple
all while bragging about its great
cooling system
on the plus side the ineffective single
fan system
isn't extremely loud but it is
definitely audible and annoying
and thankfully i did find one
alternative for those that don't need
the maximum performance of the high end
but also don't want a fan that's running
at full blast when they push their
machine
i used fan control software to manually
set the fan at about half speed
which is barely louder than our hvac
noise in our room
and ran the same cinebench test which
really pushes the machine
and to my surprise the m1 was only about
five percent slower
than running the fan at full blast and
the temps were about the same
this proves that the fan is doing almost
nothing but making noise
and of course you can also fine-tune the
rpm and set up profiles
to maximize the performance compared to
noise i'll go ahead and leave a link to
the software down in the description
below
and now let's get into performance which
is really good
especially on the higher end one for two
reasons if you've been keeping up with
the m1 chips you'll know that for
certain optimized programs like
xcode it beats even my 5 000 mac pro
and for logic pro music production it
performs incredibly well compared to
previous intel models
for these optimized apps apple silicon
can beat out processors and graphics
that have much more performance for
example angelica's 27-inch imac has
about double the graphics performance
but the m1 chip
cuts through 4k footage easier and
renders video faster
due to its dedicated encoders and
decoders that also allow to play back
the newest
toughest hevc footage flawlessly where
most computers
even my mac pro can't and have to
convert the footage first
apple even went as far as saying that it
can edit 8k
video which i was skeptical of but it
did in fact edit some ak footage that i
shot with the new sony a1
because of this even though her imac is
technically more powerful
for the type of work that we do the m1
is actually faster
and more efficient but don't think that
this machine will handle anything that
you'll throw at it
the issue it runs into is not having
enough raw graphics performance
when you layer too much effects or if
you're working with files or even
programs that haven't properly been
optimized
where more expensive and more powerful
intel machines will be faster
but with that said every month more
programs are optimized for apple silicon
and in those cases these lower price
machines are incredibly fast and for
general use such as web browsing and
simple apps
the imac is incredibly responsive making
my mac pro feel slow
when i go back to it for most people
looking to buy a 24 inch imac
even those that do photo and video
editing this machine will do a great job
punching way above its weight and most
average 27 inch imac users can downgrade
to an m1 imac
but for those that have high spec models
or imac pros
i would wait for the larger m1x models
to get more raw graphics performance
and now for the buyer's guide section so
you guys don't waste your money or make
a mistake
to start off those that are doing very
basic tasks like web browsing
email watching videos and never doing
anything more difficult than that
i would just go for the base model 8
gigs of ram is plenty and 256 gigs of
storage should be enough space
especially if you use icloud for photos
now if you like convenience or if you
have multiple users i would definitely
spend the 50
extra for the touch id keyboard but the
30 is more for ethernet isn't really
needed unless you
really want to use ethernet because the
wi-fi is very fast on this machine now
for people who want to do
some photo and video editing and other
intensive tasks like gaming
or could possibly do them and years down
the line definitely get the 1500
model and if you're doing 4k or raw
photo editing or you want your machine
to last a very long time
i would upgrade to 16 gigs of ram since
that's something that you can't upgrade
later
storage capacity is always a really
tough choice because it really depends
on your usage patterns
personally i go with the smallest
capacity because i store my files
externally and in the cloud but if you
don't
offload files off of your computer i
would see how much storage space you're
using on your current mac
or pc of course and then get more than
that but it gets expensive very quickly
because apple is only offering ultra
fast ssd options that
cost a lot more than external ssds
i'll go ahead and leave my ssd
recommendation down in the description
below
overall the m1 imac is an incredible
machine and it would be perfect if apple
kept the proper
right side fan and heatsink in the base
model
and it would be an absolute steal at
12.99
unfortunately or fortunately for apple
most people should spend at least
fifteen hundred dollars
which makes it less of a value but still
a great all-in-one machine
which not only looks great no matter
where you put it but also has a great
display which alone is worth
at least seven hundred dollars a
keyboard and mouse that's valued at two
hundred dollars
a good webcam microphone and speakers
and of course
extremely good performance with the m1
especially for
the money it does exactly what apple
designed it for
a desktop machine that works great for
most people
now if you want to see a dedicated
comparison against the intel versions
or the base model against the high end
go ahead and check that out
right over there and click that circle
above to subscribe to help us reach
1 million subscribers before the end of
the year we'd greatly appreciate it
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video